[Music]
thank you
tonight's topic is the nature of time
and time is one of our most precious
commodities perhaps the most precious
commodity i mean we
enter the world we're given a certain
allotment of time we don't know how much
time we're given
after we exhaust that allotment of time
it's all over
so thank you very much for coming and
good night
now we
have spent
countless hours decades centuries
pondering the nature of time
and as we'll discuss here tonight there
is a lot we understand about time but if
we even reflect on
the starting point where you would
imagine that we begin our exploration of
time the definition of time
we still are hard-pressed to give that
definition
right time certainly has to do with
change
that's how we recognize that time has
elapsed
but trying to really get at the heart of
what time actually is
proves extraordinarily difficult john
wheeler
who i suspect many of you are familiar
with that name one of the great
physicists of our age
who passed away not too long ago
he famously said
that time is nature's way of ensuring
that everything doesn't happen all at
once
and certainly that is a quality of time
but trying to get at the heart of what
it is
is difficult so what we're going to do
here tonight is we're going to approach
this deep question from three different
perspectives we're going to kind of try
to triangulate on a deeper appreciation
understanding intuition about time so in
this first chapter this first act if you
will of the discussion
i'm going to focus upon
how physics deals with the nature of
time and when i conclude i'm then going
to bring out a guest neuroscientist is
going to give us a way of thinking about
time by focusing upon the biological
structures that allow us to
experience time the passage of time and
various other qualities that we will
discuss
and then in the third part i'm going to
bring out a cognitive scientist who will
help us think about time from the
perspective
of language
and culture and allow us to
put these perspectives together and in
part four we'll have a a joint
conversation where we'll try to have
some of a free-for-all to try to see
where we can find places of coincidence
differences and ultimately hopefully
give you a richer sense of the nature of
time so to begin
physics of time
what we have done
to try to get a handle on time over the
course of many centuries is devise ever
better ways of measuring the passage of
time now how do we do that how do we
measure the passage of time well it's a
fairly straightforward procedure
we try to find processes out there in
the natural world
that are cyclical that are repetitive
and if the repetition is stable if it's
something that is reliable in the sense
that cycle after cycle after cycle
they're all the same
we use those cycles to count how much
time has gone by so of course as we're
all familiar in the old days we began
that process by making use of the
cyclical
notion of the earth's spinning and that
allowed us to introduce the sundial
right so as the earth spins and the
position of the sun changes the shadow
that we see here will move around and in
that way we have a means of measuring
the passage of time
now that is making use of an
astronomical
phenomenon but we can go further and
make use of mechanical phenomenon and
the step in that direction
can be
viewed in this picture here we consider
a pendulum right so basic physics that
we learned in the 16 1700s tells us that
if we have a situation like this where
we have a mass that is swinging on an
arm
basic physics tells us that if you know
anything about the length of the arm and
the nature of the gravitational
acceleration you can calculate how this
is going to swing and it's regular and
you can use that as a clock but then you
know we went further from this and we
recognize that there are certain
materials certain crystals quartz
crystals that if you apply a voltage to
them they oscillate in a very regular
manner and that gives rise to the kinds
of watches that were well known and well
used in the last 10 20 30 40 years
but even this is a technology that we
can improve upon and we have improved
upon it by making use of atomic clocks
in which for instance this is an example
where a cesium atom can be excited by
bombarding it with laser pulses and then
it itself will pulse
and in fact we now define the second by
counting the number of vibrations of the
radiation that comes out of this cesium
133 atomic species
so this is a a wonderful progression in
the history of trying to measure this
thing called time because the device
that i just showed you atomic clocks
they are so accurate they're so reliable
in their repetitive process their
cyclical process
that some of these devices will lose
less than a second in a million or 10
million years
so that's kind of amazing right when you
think about our ability to measure this
thing called time and yet we reflect
back on the starting point of the
discussion where i said we don't
actually know what it is that we are
measuring
so it's a curious tension between our
stunning ability to measure it but our
lack of full understanding of what it is
that we are measuring but even so
we've gone
further beyond simply measuring the
passage of time we've been able to
through certain incredible minds that
our species has produced albert einstein
in particular we've gained insight into
qualities of time
that
are counter-intuitive they are not the
features of time
that we experience
so now i want to turn to
three qualities of time
one having to do with the rate at which
time passes and this is where einstein's
ideas will come to the fore
and then i'll follow that with a
discussion brief discussion of two other
qualities of time that are within our
intuition the intuition that i think we
all have that time flows right i think
we all have that sense that time flows
and then the third will be our intuition
that the future and the past are
radically different
and i'll give you some insight into what
physics has to say about that quality of
time and we'll see that actually it is
not aligned with our understanding of
the basic laws of physics so for the
first quality
the passage of time i think most of us
have an intuition unless you've studied
physics or you read popular books on
these ideas but
certainly ingrained in our bones is the
sensation that time elapses the same
regardless of where you are how you're
moving the gravitational field that
you're experiencing
and einstein was the first individual to
come along and establish that that
intuition is just not right and one way
of quickly getting at this insight
is to remember that einstein's
special theory of relativity is based
upon the idea experimentally verified
that the speed of light is constant
speed of light doesn't change we like
things that don't change
they're the things in which we can
anchor our understanding and to make use
of that constant nature of the speed of
light we can build a very special kind
of clock some of you no doubt are
familiar with this clock it's called a
light clock it consists of two mirrors
that are facing each other and a ball of
light that bounces between the two
mirrors so i think i can show you an
example of that here so how do you make
a clock out of this you simply count the
bounces so tick tock tick tock and you
simply count the ticks in the talks and
in that way this becomes a clock what i
want to do is i want to compare
the passage of time on two of these
light clocks
where i'm going to in just a moment set
that second clock on the right in motion
when they're sitting side by side of
course the passage of time on them is
absolutely identical the question that
einstein asked is if you put that second
clock in motion what will happen and let
me first describe
what you'll see in the next little
sequence here but just to sort of orient
your thinking imagine that i have a
light clock right here this is the
bottom mirror this is the top mirror and
you see the ball of light bouncing up
and down between those two mirrors now
as i walk right as i'm walking along
imagine following the beam of light the
ball of light so it starts down here and
as i'm walking it's going to hit the
upper mirror from my perspective the
clock's not even moving so it's
certainly going to hit that upper mirror
but the trajectory therefore will be to
start down here
hit the upper mirror in this location as
i continue to move the ball of light
will go on a second diagonal trajectory
and hit the bottom mirror over here so
as you watch this clock if i darken the
theater and the only thing that you
could see was the ball of light you
would see the tick tocks going
tick
tock
and the beautiful thing about that
trajectory is that it's longer than the
straight up and down trajectory
but the speed of the light is unchanged
and therefore if the light is traveling
a longer distance at the same speed
it's going to take it longer to do it so
the tick tocks are going to slow down so
let me show you that in the sequence
over here so now i'm going to put that
light clock on the right in motion
and watch the trajectory of that photon
that ball of light
and you'll see it follows the double
diagonal trajectory
a longer trajectory now look at the tick
tocks nine versus eight ten versus nine
time is slowing down
on the moving
clock
and einstein was the first person to
realize
that time is not something that's
universal in the sense that isaac newton
thought it was
time on a clock in motion from our
perspective watching it
ticks off more slowly and it's not just
a light clock that light clock is
representative of the passage of time
itself
so if you had sufficiently good
resolution to watch the biological
processes inside my body as i'm moving
right now they would also be slowing
down at exactly the same rate as the
slowing down of the tick tock on that
light clock
time in motion slows down now why don't
we know about this
because we travel at speeds that are
very slow compared to the speed of light
how fast is the speed of light
go around the earth seven times in a
single second
at the speed of light since our speed is
so slow we don't realize this
intuitively in our bones einstein
figured this out
now he also figured something else out
he figured out that gravity has an
impact
on the passage of time this is his
general theory of relativity 1915 he
writes down the equations and he
realizes that in a sense i'll talk a
little metaphorically in order to just
get the basic idea across
gravity in some sense pulls not just on
matter
it also pulls
on time
which means that the stronger the
gravitational field that you are in the
stronger gravity pulls on time slowing
down
its passage
stronger gravity time slows down it
elapses at a slower rate so just to give
you an example of that
we can consider say the empire state
building
imagine you have a clock of any variety
it doesn't matter that's sitting on the
ground over here
and it's ticking away at a usual rate
but now let's imagine going way to the
top of the empire state building where
gravity is not quite as strong as on the
ground
and the stronger gravity on the ground
means that the clock on the ground will
tick off slower and you can begin to see
the time difference
between them
now again
not to scale
right
the time difference would be tiny right
billionths of a second
but
it's not the size of the time difference
that really matters for our attempt to
understand the nature of time is the
fact that time is not the same it's not
universal it depends not only on how
you're moving it depends on the
gravitational field
that you are experiencing now having
said that
the reason it's so small is because the
gravitational pull of the earth is
relatively weak
but if you were to go near the edge of a
black hole where gravity is much
stronger
than the time warp associated with being
nearer to the black hole versus farther
from the black hole
could result in a significant time warp
time difference between clocks that are
ticking at those different locations and
of course there have been
ingredients there have been examples in
popular culture that have made use of
that scientific fact right what's the
most recent and perhaps most famous film
that made use of this fact
interstellar right so an interstellar if
you recall there's a black hole and some
of the astronauts go relatively close to
that black hole and that affects their
passage of time and just to remind you
kip thorne who was the
science advisor and had the initial idea
i believe for this film
made sure that everything was as
scientifically accurate as it could be
so this is an example where just a few
hours according to you know matthew
mcconaughey and hathaway down by the
black hole
translates into 23 years up on the
mothership because time is elapsing so
slow in the powerful gravitational pull
of a black hole relative to the rate at
which time is elapsing
elsewhere
and you know i've known about these
ideas now i don't know 35
40 years maybe
they never cease to be utterly stunning
because they're so different from what
our brains
intuitively think about the nature of
time
two other qualities of time that i told
you i'd talk about not just the passage
of time but also this intuitive
sensation
that time flows right the time somehow
is pulling us from second to second to
second in a relentless way that often
poetically is described as say the flow
of a river the flow of time
and to
get a feel for that here's a sort of
rough way of thinking about that we kind
of think of motion in the world
as in some sense being a series of
snapshots i'm showing them discrete but
you'd really imagine them being
continuous and it's moment after moment
after moment and these snapshots just
keep on going forward as time elapses
toward the future
and this often gives us the sense
that the only thing that's real
right is the present moment right the
present moment is what's real and
somehow
the past is gone and the future is yet
to be and there's something very curious
about that way of thinking about time
because a moment in time
represents a quality of time
that is its most basic ingredient
change only is observable by comparing
one moment to another moment a moment
itself can't change by definition it is
the ingredient by which we can see
change by comparing one moment to the
next
so if we think about the present moment
either in this metaphor of snapshots or
an equivalent metaphor that often is
used as sort of a projector right so
it's as if
time is going by and the only thing
that's real is the moment that's
illuminated illuminated the now is
illuminated by the projector of time and
all of the frames that are before or
after the one that's being projected
somehow are gone the ones that have yet
to be illuminated future those that have
already been illuminated or the past but
if you think about this there's it's
strange because this is saying that
a moment of time
is real by virtue of being illuminated
but to be not illuminated in this way of
thinking about things would be for that
moment to be changed it's as if you're
saying that moment exists in two
varieties
when it's illuminated and when it's not
but if a moment can't change then that's
an incoherent notion because that
suggests that there are two versions of
that moment the illuminated one and the
not illuminated one
and this kind of thinking when
really wetted together with einstein's
relativity gives a very different way of
thinking about time
in which we imagine that every moment is
as real as every other moment it's not
just that the present is real and the
past is gone the future's yet to be
every moment is as real as every other
past still exists
future exists
present exists
and this is what gave rise to
einstein's own poetic description
where he said the difference the
distinction between past present and
future is only an illusion however
persistent
and part of what we'll do in the second
part of this discussion
is try to get a feel for that
distinction between our intuition past
has gone future yet to be present is
real
and
what science from the point of view of
relativity and even just logic seems to
be telling us about the reality of all
of time
all right final
quality of time that i will
focus upon
is our intuitive sense
that
time has a direction
time has what we call an arrow right we
are so familiar with the fact
that when you look out at physical
happenings in the world they seem to
always unfold in one temporal
orientation right the canonical examples
that we'd like to use you know if you
drop an egg it splatters but it never
unsplatters you know if someone dives
off a diving board they go into the
water but you never see somebody jumping
out of the water untumbling and landing
on the diving board and in fact you
laugh
and that's an important fact because
when you see reverse run films
the reason you laugh is because it's so
ludicrous
relative to your understanding your
intuition about the nature of time
but here's the amazing fact
when you look at the laws of physics as
currently configured
all laws of physics when properly
interpreted so i won't go into the
nuances of that but
all laws of physics have the quality
that they treat the future and the past
symmetrically identically on equal
footing
which means when we physicists study the
laws of motion
any sequence of events that can unfurl
in one direction
the reverse sequence is allowed by the
laws
of physics
and in fact there's an algorithm
for
ensuring
that if you have
for instance any physical unfolding if
you want to reverse it all you need to
do
is reverse the motions of the particles
that are involved and there's a little
clip that i'll show you
which also has a certain temporal
quality to it sort of shows me as as a
young man so i'll sort of disappear for
this little bit but this illustrates
this point about the arrow of time
actually being reversible we all know
what will happen if i drop this glass of
wine
[Music]
now the idea that this mess could
somehow reverse itself and form back
into a solid glass filled with wine
seems absurd
but according to the laws of physics
this can happen all i need to do is
reverse the velocities of everything
every piece of glass every drop of wine
every molecule and atom in the liquid
glass table and air just reverse all
their velocities
and voila
[Music]
ah if only we could reverse time as easy
as that
but the point is
here is a very basic quality of
experience that things seem to only
unfold in one orientation we only ever
see things unfold in one orientation but
that's really an environmental effect
it's really the fact that we can't
reverse all those velocities as i did in
the little clip there simply because
it's too hard to do
but if we could the laws of physics say
that things would
run in reverse so this gives some feel
of the disjuncture between our intuition
both for the passage of time
with special relativity moving bodies
general relativity with gravity
our sensation that time flows and our
sense that time has an arrow our
intuition is sort of at loggerheads with
these fundamental qualities of time
and we're going to explore the tension
between what we understand about time
from physics
and our perception of time with some of
the world's experts that can give us
some insight into the nature of that
dysjuncture so to do that let's bring
out a neuroscientist from the brain
research institute and the integrative
center for learning and memory at ucla
he's a leading researcher on how the
brain tells time and neural computation
please welcome to the stage dean
guanamono
all right so
you saw in that discussion there and you
already know from your own knowledge of
the physics side of this discussion
that
there is this tension between what
physics has found
and
our intuition about how the world works
and i gather part of the explanation
there must lie in the fact that our
brains evolved in order to survive and
to survive you don't have to know about
these curiosities about the nature of
time but can you take us into your
understanding of how the brain processes
time how it keeps time
so i think there's a big difference here
between physicists and neuroscientists
in that neuroscience tend to be
implicitly
[Music]
accept the notion that only the present
is real and the future is not yet real
and the past is no longer real that's
because the brain is an inherently
temporal organ in many ways if we can
say that the brain has a main function
its main function
is to store information about the past
in order to predict and prepare for the
future by acting on the present so the
fact that we talk about memory and
future means that we're sort of assuming
that we have the ability to change the
future and that's that's the currency of
evolution the degree to which i can
anticipate what's going to happen sure
gives me a powerful uh evolutionary
advantage so
so starting from that um distinction
then the question is okay how does the
brain do that right and then the brain
um learns we have we form memories we
store information from the past and the
implicit idea there is that that past no
longer exists except within
our neural circuits and then we predict
the future
um and to predict the future you need to
tell time it's not sufficient for your
weatherman to say
um it's going to rain
it's helpful if they tell you it's going
to rain tomorrow or the day after
so the question of how the brain tells
time is key and brian is there a
structure in the brain that's
specifically oriented toward keeping
time so that was one theory um decades
ago that maybe you have some central
clock in your brain sort of like a
computer has a clock chip
um that sort of controls all the
temporal um processing undone by the
computer so that was one theory
um
but the point is is really that because
timing is so important for everything we
do right now you are paying attention to
the timing in my speech but you're also
paying attention to the time on that
clock over there oh you saw me glance
over there
to um
to to time the pace of this so yeah so
the brain is attempting to predict
what's going to happen by telling time
and let me give you so for example right
now your brain is unconsciously
attempting to predict what is about to
happen
and
by pausing my speech
i created a temporal prediction error in
your brain because you were
unconsciously attempting to predict what
was going to happen it didn't happen
so then you became consciously aware
of um and brian started thinking uh oh
he forgot what he was going to say
or the audience said
man this guy's boring
but
and another thing happens there brian is
because it was sort of an awkward
silence
you probably became more aware of the
passage of time and this is the
fundamental point you you just
approached right which is the flow of
time the notion that time is not
a static frame in the movie but flowing
and that's where as you alluded to the
clash comes between physics and
neuroscience and neuroscientists tend to
blame physicists for not understanding
time and the neuroscientists and the
physicists hope that the neuroscientists
will explain where this illusion comes
from and i think that that will be an
issue
that maybe we can um talk about um
shortly but regarding how the brain
tells time
um you mentioned that throughout um
human civilization we've been inventing
more and more powerful ways to tell time
and today
we don't measure anything as well as we
tell measure time so in indeed we
measure space by telling time a meter is
defined by how far light goes
um in a specific period of time so
and all these man-made clocks tend to
rely on a fairly um simple conceptual
concept right which brian mentioned
which is just
the counting of these oscillations
whether the oscillation of a pendulum
oscillation of a quartz crystal or
oscillation of the vibrations of a
cesium atom the brain the the timers or
the clocks created by the brain
are fundamentally different from those
that are within the brain so the brain
does not tell time by counting the ticks
of an oscillator so yes there are
oscillators for example your circadian
clock is an oscillator that tells you
um when to get up and when to eat
but the neurons in your brain that are
oscillating they have no idea of how
much time how many times they have
oscillated so something that brian
didn't quite mention was that a key
feature of using a quartz crystal is
something has to count the ticks yeah
and the same thing with a atomic clock
so while the
circadian clock
neurons are oscillating they haven't a
clue if they've oscillated a thousand
times or ten thousand times or a hundred
thousand times so
the other thing amazing about man-made
clocks is the same atomic clock
can count
picoseconds
microseconds milliseconds seconds days
years and so forth so the brain is also
able to tell time across
vast scales but they're fundamentally
different mechanisms so your circadian
clock does not have a second hand
the time the timers are the circuits in
your brain
that um allow you to
pick up the pause in my speech have a
second hand but don't have an hour hand
so the brain has many many clocks so the
answer to your question
is is no there's not a centralized clock
um that tells time across scales and
solves all our temporal problems
and i mean from a from an evolutionary
perspective it's clear that having the
capacity
to keep track of various temporal
durations
has survival value right i mean internal
processes that need to coordinate the
production of proteins and different
processes have to happen in a certain
rhythm you know we have to know to get
up
you know if we didn't get up that would
be the end of it all so with this being
the case is it
true that say across all animals they
keep track of time in the same way or
are we different from
uh other members of the animal kingdom
we inherited a lot of the clocks of our
of our mammalian ancestors so the the
ability to tell time the circadian clock
is very similar you don't even have to
have a brain to have a circadian clock
so bacteria and plants have circadian
clocks and by the way something you
mentioned is a very good point is that
um we call it a circadian clock but even
the circadian clock is really a
prediction mechanism because as you said
it's not about necessarily waking up
it's about preparing the body to engage
the correct proteins and hormones so
it's more of a
prediction device than an actual clock
and animals have um ways to tell time on
the millisecond scale too so that's very
very similar across species what's
different
is our ability to conceptualize time so
humans and animals different so if you
look at human evolution
all animals try to predict what's about
to happen you know the simple act of
throwing something towards you is it's a
prediction act that you're going to
catch it or something so you have to
look into the future or or a
cat that's jumping up in the air to
catch a bird right it's predicting the
future
humans
did this amazing thing that they went
from predicting the future to making the
future so the simple act of planting a
seed
to say okay instead of searching for
food i'm going to make the food and that
food will come to me so this is what we
call mental time travel so somewhere
along the lines our ancestors became
able to
engage in the ability to travel short or
long periods of time in the past and in
the future and this totally in their
heads totally in our heads so so the
fact of the matter is as a physicist i
don't know what your position on um time
travel is but you probably agree that
it's not a practical matter so the best
time machine we have is our brain
um and our ability to stimulate you and
i
um
simulated in our brain being here to
prepare for tonight it might not look
that way but um
we did
and um
so
so that ability gauge and mental time
travel to plant the seed and reap the
the products of that is beyond the
cognitive ability of
as far as we know of all other animals
and what about
the phenomenon that i mentioned that
is probably the most familiar quality
intuitive quality of time that sensation
that all these moments are somehow
stitching together is there evidence
that we have
a minimal amount of time that will
constitute something that we're aware of
and i'm assuming that there is for that
and given that
can you tell us anything about the
process in the brain that stitches
together all of those moments into
something that feels continuous
no
thank you
so there's two aspects to that question
so first there's what's happening
unconsciously so unconsciously our
ability to pick up differences in small
amounts of time is actually quite
astounding given that neurons are so
slow for example
sound localization from my right ear to
my left ear takes maybe a hundred
microseconds and you can easily pick
that up but that's unconscious
now um
at the conscious level
the question of if there's a quantal
time exactly um
is is a bit different and there's not
really but it's very flexible so i think
you're referring to the question of our
conscious perception of time and that's
a that's a much deeper question so first
place of course
um there's a delay so when we process
each other's speech
were in a sense living in the past a bit
because it takes any computational
device with its computer or the brain
um some finite amount of time to process
that information and but then that's
natural so that's just
a consequence of physics
now there's a deeper question here
which is
when do we become conscious of something
and our although you might think that
you're perceiving my speech as one
continuous flow of the river
it's really not that's a bit of a
meta illusion or a mental construct in
that your brain
processes things in chunks
and then stitches them together but the
amount of that stitch is actually
variable it's not fixed let me try to
give you an example by saying two
sentences here
the mouse pad and computer are new
in second sentence
the mouse was eaten by the cat
okay so i think hopefully you understood
um both sentences had the word mouse
and they had different meanings
but you only knew the meaning by the
word that came after right okay so if i
say the mouse pad and computer are new
you don't know what i was going to say
until what comes after but most of you
i'm guessing
didn't
edit in time
backwards to readjust your
interpretation of the mouse i don't know
i'm just assuming you didn't so um
clearly your brain
is
chunking things in time so the way to
think about this
is your unconscious brain is
continuously processing information in a
more or less linear manner but
consciousness which is really a small
fraction of what goes on in our brain
is generated once the unconscious brain
arrives at some reasonable narrative
some reasonable story of
what's happening in the external world
and generates conscious sometimes that
most of the time fortunately
that story is correlated with its in the
real world sometimes it's not and that's
an illusion or hallucination
now speaking of illusions or
hallucinations you know i've had
friends
tell me about
psychoactive drugs
and these friends
have described their experiences so
vividly that i almost feel like i've had
those experiences
so i'm i'm wondering um they describe
situations
in in which
the effect of the psychoactive drug was
to radically change their perception of
time in a variety of different ways
so clearly you know a chemical flowing
through
the brain can radically change
everything that you're describing as the
normal
neurological functioning yeah and um
you'll be glad to know that you can um
feel this without having to do as your
friends do take those drugs
just
by
engaging in something that's really
boring or an exciting near-death
experiment or experience or jumping from
a plane if you don't want to do the
drugs
and then you're using your own drugs
literally the neuromodulators that do
that so so there's again two levels to
this question what's happening at this
um unconscious circuitry level and
neural modulators and the chemistry in
your brain whether they're altered by
pharmacological compounds
or not
modulate the neural circuits within our
brain so they can accelerate
the processing of the neural dynamics or
not changing our perception of time so
if we
accelerate the neural dynamics through
some pharmacological means
then our internal clock is going faster
and the external which means that in
relatively speaking the external clock
is going slower so we are left with the
perception that time is slowing down
um now that doesn't really explain the
consciousness which i think is what your
your your friends were referring to
the conscious perception there and that
is is a much deeper question because
it's tied to consciousness
and in a way i think it's it's the wrong
question and let me
if you give me some leeway here i'm
going to make an analogy
so
there's an illusion about body awareness
and the illusion is um phantom limbs or
phantom pain right so people who don't
have an arm often feel that arm as as it
still there
and um this is very paradoxical and
strange for for us who have never felt
how can you feel something that's not
there
and the reason you can is we know
that um
the feeling of the body is not happening
in the body it's happening in the brain
so if i'm to hurt my finger my brain is
projecting that pain out here so the
mystery of phantom limbs
is not the phantom limb it's our normal
limbs so it's mis
a leading to ask what causes phantom
limbs the correct question
is what causes our normal body
perception my point is
is that the same is true in time so
looking at the distortions of time is
really
the least of the mysterious questions
the the more mysterious questions what
our normal perception
of time is and and that's inextricably
linked with consciousness and and it's a
difficult question so given that
you know um
a thought that's always in the back of
my mind
a somewhat disturbing thought actually
is that we as physicists have spent a
lot of energy and effort trying to work
out the qualities of time and i
described some of them in in part one of
the the program here tonight
of course everything that we figure out
we figure out with the same gloppy gray
structure inside of our heads which
perhaps
for evolutionary reasons gives us a
certain kind of temporal experience of
reality
could it be the case
that a different architecture
might have led to a radically different
way of
experiencing time and a different way of
of thinking about time out there in the
real world absolutely and i think but
here here's
as you said
so the brain evolved under to survive in
a world governed by the laws of physics
right so this is a pretty stringent test
um
but the laws of physics acting out
in a very limited domain of experience
so
our intuitions about quantum mechanics
are horrible
and our intuitions about general
relativity are horrible because those
domains aren't particularly important
for survival
time is though right
so
time is not a property that's limited
quantum mechanics or um general
relativity it's very mesoscopic so i
would argue that we have to take very
seriously are intuitions about the past
not being real the present being real
and the future
um
uh also not being real yet so because i
struggled to see but why
i don't mean to interrupt but that's a
key point right there between the
physics and the biological perspective
because when i think about
biology in the brain i always think hey
so this thing
had one goal which was to survive long
enough so that the bearer would reach
reproductive maturity and pass on the
genes to the next generation
and my view has long been
that that's radically different goal
than figuring out the true nature of
reality in fact moreover my view has
long been that those of our forebears
who may have been prescient and knew
about the strangeness of time that came
safe from einstein when they were out
there on the planes thinking about time
dilation and general relativity they got
eaten
they weren't focused on the goal which
was survival
and and so when you say we have to take
seriously that sort of the past has gone
the future's yet to be
i wonder why you say that so
i say that because unlike
the our forebears that were thinking
about quantum mechanics
they would be
um
and fortunately and same with general
relativity fortunately einstein was not
eaten
but with time
it is critical for survival because as i
said the brain is a device that stores
information about the past that's memory
in order to predict the future and
that's what you're doing
so i think the question that we have to
try to resolve
is whether
um
the temporal component of of of our
conscious experience is real or not let
me try to give you an analogy
another one in terms of color okay yeah
sure we know that in physics color
doesn't really exist
what we have
is
wavelength of electromagnetic radiation
the brain the color is evolution's hack
to build a spectrometer
and
and it's imperfect but it's pretty damn
good right so newton used his perception
of color to make very valid influences
about the physics of of light
now
i think
by the same reason
color is adaptive because it tells us
about it's correlated with the real
world i think
our feeling of the flow of time
wouldn't have evolved if it weren't
correlated with the real world from an
evolutionary perspective now my question
to you brian is the following if
an omniscient being came down
and to you personally
and
assured you that the past present and
future are different
that the present is in some sense more
real than the future past obviously we
know that absolute present doesn't exist
because that's been well tested because
we know clocks
change at different speeds but that
doesn't really say that the present is
different from is not fundamentally
different from the past or future so if
that being came to you and said that
would you have to go in there and
rewrite any of the laws of physics or
could you still use the same laws well
it's a good question and actually it's a
relevant one because
i have been visited by the
omniscient thing with was this with your
friends no no yeah
so so so here's my view
my view is that much of what we're
talking about tonight is absolutely
vital
from a human scale perspective because
we're beings that live in the world and
we want to have a deeper understanding
of this quality that is with us every
moment of every day there's barely a
sentence that i can utter that doesn't
have a temporal quality in it so it's so
vital to everything that we do that we
want to understand it more deeply
from the standpoint of fundamental
physics much of what we're talking about
just doesn't matter
if you look at the equations of
relativity or quantum mechanics you can
use those equations to make predictions
about what will happen in various
experiments without having to commit to
whether the past has gone or the future
is yet to be
so so it's an interesting
state of affairs where
i don't think that i would need to
rewrite the laws of physics at all given
this information assuming that it was
true
because ultimately
this is a layer of human
interpretation that's sitting upon the
more fundamental understanding now
that's not to say
that
our current understanding down here is
the final story i don't think that it is
my guess is that there will come a point
and it's starting to bubble up right now
in fundamental physics
where we'll recognize that time is not
as basic
to the laws as we once thought
there is there's evidence to suggest and
this is things coming from quantum
gravity and string theory which are
certainly on the edge of speculation
but there is reason to suspect
that time is something that emerges from
a more fundamental starting point the
analogy that i like to use is
temperature so we all know what it means
when something's hot or something's cold
right totally intuitive
we learned many decades ago that there's
a more fundamental underpinning to that
which is when something's hot its
molecules are moving fast when it's cold
its molecules are moving slow and
temperature simply is a measure of that
average kinetic motion so that says that
temperature emerges from a more basic
starting point having to do with the
motion of atoms now i'm my belief and
this is not iconic to me there are many
in my field who feel the same way that
there is an analogous
notion of atoms but not for matter but
for time that there's some more basic
fundamental ingredient that when it be
is in the right configuration
time emerges but when it's not in that
configuration there isn't even a
conception of time
and that's why these ideas are sort of
very high level however much they matter
to us as human beings i don't think they
matter to the fundamental laws of
physics so to me your answer in which
you
won't have to rewrite the current laws
of physics
is very interesting in that
maybe
that gives us
room
for
the present
being different from the future in the
past and saying that it's an
interpretation let me just say one thing
so
in the end humans and this might be a
good transition to bring in lara
in the end humans are literally just
unusually smart apes um we really have
no right to think that we um should
understand the laws of the universe
what's surprising
um is that we've gotten as far as we can
given that the brain has many glitches
many limitations many bugs the most
powerful debugging tool that we have
i think is is mathematics yeah and once
once some genius
conjures up these sets of equations the
rest of us can put in numbers to those
equations
and predict
what's happening in the external world
now
once you're able to do that
you have the power of the science
underlying it but once we start
interpreting them then
the word interpret means it's being
filtered through your brain
so
i would
pose to you the possibility that
given how the brain was built evolved we
have on we have a bias to interpret
those equations in the context of the
spatialization of time um because that's
the best way
to make sense of those equations given
the little the the very
ephemeral very limited um computational
advice we have at our disposal to
interpret those equations yes yeah
and i would agree with that and that is
a great point for us to transition to
the language interpretive quality that
we humans impose on time so from one
intelligent ape to another i uh thank
you for the conversation we'll bring you
out in just a moment after this thank
you dean bonamano
all right let's now bring out a
cognitive scientist at the university of
california san diego whose research
focuses on the relationship between mind
world and language named one of 25
visionaries changing the world by the
utne reader please welcome lara
voraditzky
thank you for being here thanks for
having me so we just finished that
discussion on the note of
mathematics as a language
well we didn't quite stop at all that's
why you're here so so we think about
mathematics as a language but one that
perhaps gives us
deeper insight into the nature of
reality than natural language which is
our attempt to describe in a way that we
can make intuitive sense of the world
around us
so when it comes to to language and the
language that we use to describe
everything not just time itself
where do we stand in understanding where
language came from the origin of
language we know a lot you know about
the origin of the universe i can tell
you all sorts of details about that
how have you guys done in figuring out
the origin of language well we're still
waiting for the time machine that you
were supposed to deliver that work that
would that would really help yeah um the
reason i say that is that language is uh
a soft historical artifact it doesn't
leave a trace in the fossil record so
it's actually very very hard to know
a lot of solid facts about the history
of language after you go back more than
say 10 000 years right so
the start of written language of course
helps but we only have written records
for a small handful
in only a few thousand years and then
beyond that we can make some inferences
by the patterns of interrelatedness
between languages
but once you get past a few thousand
years we're really making a lot of
conjectures right so the time machine
would be very handy okay we will keep
that in mind my order my order is in
it's in absolutely you'll be the first
to get one excellent um so so when when
we think about language though
i think many of us well maybe i speak
for myself language is this means of
abstracting
our experience i mean when i think about
you know i've got couple dogs at home
smart dogs but they they more or less
live in the moment i mean they do know
certain things about you know when it's
meal time and they know to behave in
certain ways when they want to go out
and so forth but for the most part the
the way that they live is in the moment
yet i and everybody else
through the power of language seem to be
able to rise above the moment and that's
when we can begin to think about the
past and imagine the future so in that
sense
is language the rubric within which our
intuition of time happens or is it the
reverse is it our experience of time
that guides the language that we use to
articulate it
certainly humans are able to entertain
ideas about the deep past and the deep
future that are unlikely to happen in
other creatures but lots of creatures
can predict things that will happen and
can maybe even reminisce or replay
experience really reminisce
well
certainly if you make a rat run a maze
for example and then measure the
activity in
the hippocampus of that rat as it's
running the maze and then measure it
while the rat is sleeping some of the
very same patterns of activity that are
specific to that geometric pattern of
the maze will be being replayed
so if you want to interpret that as a
reminiscence or a dreaming about right
and do you think that's stretching our
usual notion of reminisce a little bit
or do you seriously think that the rats
there wow that was fun that last run
through the maze you'd love to do that
again
um well i think all all of these words
that we use for mental processes are
slightly metaphorical right the brain is
not necessarily broken down into words
we have an english for things like
reminisce or
predict
there are going to be lots and lots of
different neural processes that won't
necessarily be exactly the set of words
we happen to have in english right now
so how does language
impact our our
the way that we
mentalize time i mean has this been been
studied to to to figure out the inter
relationship between the two yeah so
well let's start with the simple
observation is that there are about 7
000 different languages in the world and
each one of them offers a different
perspective not just on time but on all
other aspects of our experience of
reality
and with things like time there's a
particularly interesting conundrum to
solve because
on the one hand
time does form the very fabric of our
experience we can't experience anything
outside of time
so it's fundamental it's core
but on the other hand we don't have any
sensors for time directly right so we
can't smell time we can't touch time we
can't see time we can't hear time
and yet we construct this notion
of time that we all then uh agree to
live with so how do we create this
abstract entity in our minds and worse
how do we create ideas that go beyond
what's physically possible or
experienceable like how do we come up
with a notion like time travel
that's a very
crazy thing for humans to come up with
because
as we walk around the world we have
physical sensors in our skin we get
photons in our eyeballs we get pressure
waves in our ears we
you know squeeze our toes and bend our
knees just in the right amount to defy
gravity and then we end up with ideas
about quantum mechanics and time travel
and goals and love and principles all of
these fancy ideas that
how do they come from that physical
experience good that's a great question
so this is where i think we can turn to
language because language is a wonderful
way
of taking some of the more basic
experiences that we have
things that come from the senses things
that come from what we can observe about
the physical world
and then building on those things so in
language you can recombine things
endlessly and you can make lots of
analogies and build on those analogies
and so the fact that language allows us
to endlessly recombine and create new
ideas new thoughts just by taking old
elements and putting them together in
these different forms allows us then to
go beyond what we can experience but
different languages which have different
i mean there's a lot of similarity
between those 7 000 languages but there
are of course distinctions significant
distinctions
do those differences
show up
in the way that different cultures
approach time or think about time yeah
there actually are huge fascinating
differences in how people think about
time and it's um i'll give you a couple
of examples but um
let me start with this uh a very simple
uh difference is um
the direction in which you read and
write
changes
in which direction you think time flows
so for a normal english speaker time
flows from left to right where the past
is laid out on the left the future is on
the right if you see someone gesturing
for example you'll see this
if you read from right to left then time
goes in the opposite direction so if you
ask hebrew speakers to lay out
pictures or arabic speakers they'll lay
them out in the opposite direction
and this is such a
pervasive
experience for us that we imagine things
unfolding in our minds in a particular
direction if you just ask people
suppose i tell you
bill is giving flowers to mary draw me a
picture that shows that people who read
from left to right like english speakers
will
draw bill on the left and mary on the
right
whereas people who read from right to
left will draw the line
on the right mary on the left going the
other direction
and
not not only is it
just that we imagine these things but
it's so deeply built into our brain that
if you
damage the part of the brain that
represents for example the left side of
space yeah it also
disrupts the imagined left side of time
right of course time doesn't have a left
side you're a physicist you know that
so there's no there's no such thing as a
left side of time but in our minds there
is and it is it should mean that
if i'm an english speaker
and the left for me represents the past
and i suspect from many others you're
saying if there is damage to my brain
which impacts that side it'll be the
past that's impacted whereas if i
um you know hebrew is my native language
it would be the future yes
exactly so uh
there's a very common kind of stroke
that you can have in the right parietal
lobe that causes left neglect so
patients with this kind of stroke might
only be able to read words on the right
side of a page they might only eat food
on the right side of their plate
complain they're still hungry you can
turn the plate for them
they might only put makeup on one side
of their face or shave one side of their
face so they're they've lost the ability
to pay attention to the left side of
their world of their visual world
and if you tell them about events that
are associated with the past like
10 years ago dean liked eating
strawberries but in 10 years he will
like eating cherries and then later i
test your memory for these events
patients who read from left to right
will have a hard time remembering things
that were associated with the past but
ones who read in the other direction
will have a harder time remembering
things associated with the future
so this is an example implicitly in
which
space is being used to represent time
and you know
as a
physicist in the in the mold of
einstein's insights that warms my heart
because we learn that space and time are
really knitted together into the fabric
of space-time so this is a a resonant
idea
but is it the case that
every culture every language
uses a spatial metaphor
to describe time or are there other ways
of doing it
there are there are a few languages uh
people have described that don't heavily
rely they don't want to they don't
heavily rely on spatial metaphor
and then sometimes you get into
semantics about what really is spatial
so like if you say the future is in the
heart and
the past is in the head
is that still spatial because those are
actually two different locations or is
it a different kind of organization it
feels different uh at first blush but uh
going back to your
uh to your thought about how space and
time seem to be intricately linked in
the mind
um
they may be more linked in the mind and
they should be uh in human minds let me
give you an example
suppose i ask you next wednesday's
meeting has been moved forward two days
what day is the meeting now that it's
been rescheduled
uh it's either friday or monday and um
who thinks friday
okay who thinks monday
okay well that's about normal
uh you guys can discuss later
um
so but that is it i mean it's sort of a
50 50ish split when
for english speakers it's about 50 50
depends on a lot of variables but here's
why people have this disagreement yeah
uh we have two different ways of talking
about time in english in
one way we talk about ourselves as
moving forward in time so we say
we're approaching the deadline we're
coming up on the holidays yes and the
other one time is moving towards us and
we're stationary so the deadline is
approaching the holidays are coming up
now if you think of yourself as moving
forward in time then moving the meeting
forward is in your direction of motion
from wednesday to friday
but if you think of time is moving then
the meeting should move forward in the
direction of time from wednesday to
monday so if you have a really over
inflated ego yeah
friday is that you know because it's
your everything is that roughly the uh
we haven't done that experiment but we
can
i mean our all our participants are very
humble right
um
but what you can do is you can get
people to think of themselves moving in
space so if i get you to imagine moving
towards a target or i get you to imagine
something physically coming towards you
your answer to the next wednesday's
meeting question will change so if
you're saying if you kind of prime my
thinking by
suggesting something yeah so if i say
imagine yourself scooting in an uh
office chair towards a goal or imagine
using a rope to bring that office chair
to you if you've just been imagining
yourself scooting you're more likely to
say friday if you've been drawing the
chair towards you you're more likely to
say monday
now here's why i say
the space and time might be too related
in the mind for this because
if i'm approaching the deadline or the
deadline is approaching me those really
should be the same thing
those shouldn't physically be different
and yet our brains are treating them as
different they're in space they're
different because there's a fixed ground
against which we're moving so if i'm
approaching you or you're approaching me
we can tell the difference between those
because there's something else that's
staying fixed this is relativity but
anyway go ahead
but then uh in time if it's really
one-dimensional
it shouldn't you shouldn't have this
quality but people seem to be treating
time as if it's actually more
dimensional than that so they're
treating these two scenarios of me
approaching the deadline as opposed to
the deadline approaching me as being
actually different psychologically
is it the case that that
effectively all languages
if they do invoke a special metaphor for
time
is it always a straight line i mean
that's again einstein's insight was to
loosen that up significantly are are
there
any cultures that have loosened it up
for whatever reason yeah so there there
are lots of variations so of course we
have circles uh
that time travels in both in uh american
culture but also other languages use
the circles much more
[Music]
of course when you're studying how
people think about time if you find what
looks like a linear representation
you don't know if that's just a small
part of a circle that you're looking at
right so it's possible that there are
even larger circles that are in there
that you're not seeing
but some people actually have broken the
idea that there should be a straight
line
at all that you could just have a bent
let me set this up there's some uh
places where time doesn't travel with
respect to the body so i've given you
examples where time can go from left to
right or right to left
but there's some places that people
don't use words like left and right at
all instead everything happens in north
south east west or some kind of cardinal
direction space i mean so a fixed
orientation relative to the earth as
opposed to relative to the orientation
of human body yes and so in languages do
well in that civilization well you would
learn again
um
in fact kids in these cultures go
through uh really uh awesome training
where their parents will say oh do you
know where grandmother's house is and
the kid might say yes it's over there
and the parent will say no no it's over
there and you get this kind of micro
correction so that you can you can get
quite precise because that's what's
expected of you
in fact in some languages like this even
your body parts would be described using
cardinal directions so you might say oh
there's a little speck on your southwest
shoe
and so if you are you serious yes
and then if you swivel like in this
chair like you're not supposed to uh
then of course it would no longer be
your southwest true a change
imagine doing the hokey pokey in a
language like that there may be a lot of
mental gymnastics
and so um for folks who
think of themselves in space that way
instead of thinking
in terms of left and right instead
thinking in terms of cardinal directions
all the time
uh
what we found is they organized time
also in cardinal directions so for
example one group that i studied the
cook tire this is an aboriginal group in
australia instead of making time go left
to right or right to left they make it
go from east to west
so if you sit someone facing south
they'll organize things from left to
right and obviously this is related to
rising setting of sun or that must be
the argument uh yeah the sun is a really
good organizing principle but it's not
the only one that people use so other
places you might live on a hill and so
then time might go uphill
other places i mean there are cultures
in which yes
there's a culture in mexico that's all
tall where time goes uphill
there's a culture in papua new guinea
where time goes down river
and there's one that we know of in papua
new guinea this is work by raphael nunez
where time this is the youknow time
flows into the village at one angle and
then it takes a turn and flows out of
the village at another angle
and this has to do with the location of
the source and the mouth of the yugna
river so these are important locations
for them and so time there follows the
exact topography of the region rather
than going in a straight line or
following some kind of other fundamental
uh
and how does that manifest i mean like
in everyday conversation
if you're like referring to the past
you're like going you know
and if you i mean are you actually
making use of these oblique angles in in
in the in in your articulation in fact
that's exactly that's exactly how he
measured it he asked people to tell
stories about things that happened in
the past or things that they're planning
to do in the future and he could measure
the spontaneous gestures that people
made as they were talking about their
plans
though very often if you speak a
language that has absolute directions
like this you're unlikely to gesture
for things that are not space because
your spatial gestures actually mean
those things so when i gesture in
english if i say oh i used to live in
san francisco or i'm going to my
grandmother's house these gestures don't
go anywhere like you can't you can't
follow these gestures and get to any
location right
whereas in these cultures you can follow
those gestures in fact i had one
conversation with a fellow in pomparou
where i asked him what he was doing the
next day and he said oh i'm going
fishing and as soon as he said that he
realized he'd just given away the
location of a secret fishing spot and so
then he started saying no fishing
he had to kind of blur blur the location
a little bit so so in in these cultures
when one goes
indoors
you're keeping track of your bodily
orientation relative to the the grid the
east-west north south grid yes so in
these particular communities people keep
track of it when they're indoors also
when they're on in unfamiliar locations
um it's just a matter of keeping a a map
it's a usually a top-down kind of
bird's-eye view map and keeping it
rotating in your mind and this actually
had this experience i was
there for a little while and
i was
really trying to stay oriented because
people treat you like you're a little
bit stupid if you're if you're not
oriented rightfully so
um
and then one day i was walking along it
was a hot day and i was frustrated about
something and i just noticed this window
pop up in my mind that was the landscape
seen from above and i was a little red
dot traversing this landscape
and then as i turned the thing rotated
in my mind's eye so that it would stay
fixed on the landscape and as soon as i
saw that and it just happened
automatically as soon as i saw that i
thought
that makes it trivial now i have this
extra little widget in my mind that uh i
can just read off a mental compass that
that's that's there with you and i then
confess this to someone kind of shyly
there i said you know this weird thing
happened i saw this and they just kind
of said well of course how else would
you do it
so i i i
have no idea whether any of these
studies have been done but if you take a
child who's grown up
in this environment where they're
thinking about time
[Music]
rather different from from the way
different spatial metaphor and so on
when they go and learn you know
newtonian physics or relativistic
physics does this impact the way that
they
absorb these ideas or do they just sort
of leave that behind and
you know become the way you know start
to think the way that that someone in
this culture would think about time well
i feel like relativistic physics has
zero relationship to how people in this
culture think about time i mean you
teach undergrads do they come in with
intuitions that seem to align with
relativistic physics well it's it's a
good point they they
they uh i feel like every i feel like
everything that physics tells us about
the structure of the world is completely
like physics tells me that this is
almost all empty
uh space and yet that would be extremely
inconvenient for me to believe if i
wanted to not walk into it right right
um
absolutely
just about every just about everything
you could tell me about that so i agree
that it's all counter-intuitive which is
in many ways the appeal to somebody like
me because
you know i'm thrilled by having my
preconceptions of the world smacked
around i mean there's nothing to me
that's more exciting
than to learn that everything that i
long thought about the world is wrong
that's a glorious moment for me but what
does happen is
you acclimate your intuition to bring it
as close as it can be to these strange
ideas for instance the ideas that we
started the discussion this evening with
the time dilation and motion and gravity
and so forth
and
my
intuition about time is now sort of
grafted on to this deeper understanding
so there's this interplay between
intuition and mathematical understanding
so there is a deep connection between
them so it does raise the question if my
starting point was radically different
because of a different cultural
perspective a different linguistic
orientation
would i think about these strange ideas
differently
i think you you would be coming from a
different starting point and i think
there are many different ways to come
from a different starting point and so
it may be
it may be that it would take you longer
it may be that you would arrive at a
somewhat different understanding
i'm not sure that we could know that
any two western physicists have actually
the same understanding of relativity
probably a lot of a lot of different
representations and uh schemas and
ways of framing and formulating uh
happen in the mind where someone might
have a more visual representation
someone else might be more symbolic or
formulaic
and so
that's maybe part of the reason that
some people come to insights sooner or
later
so but you're bringing up this really
wonderful point about the diversity of
human thought just how many different
ways we have of
conceiving of even our basic physical
facts around us and then how we use
starting from that incredible diversity
how we then used to try to rise up
higher and higher right so one final
question before we we bring dean back on
a lot of our conversation
has focused on
language as a rubric
for
understanding and organization
and you know i wonder i mean
wittgenstein had this view
that
language sort of set the limits i forget
the exact quote but it's something like
you know um
you know you know the limits of my
language set the limits of my world
something something close to that
now there's an alternate view which is
closer to my own perspective which is
that there's a whole body of
understanding
that goes beyond language i feel like i
know certain qualities of the world that
i don't articulate that i don't put into
linguistic form
do you share that or someone who sort of
lives in this world of of language as
the architects the rubric
do you feel that that that is the limit
of the world or that the world far
transcends this one little way of
describing things
well um
let me say two things one is there's
certainly some things that um
are more effable than others right and
wittgenstein gives this example of uh if
i ask you how tall is mount kilimanjaro
if you happen to know the answer that's
an easy answer to give in language
language is good for that sort of thing
but if i ask you what is the sound of a
clarinet like
it's a lot harder to give that answer in
language
and so the question is is that
inherently a property of language or
could we somehow
f the ineffable maybe develop a better
vocabulary
um
and
the other thing you said is you know are
the limits of our world the limits of
this small thing called language
language to me is not a small thing it's
an infinite thing right so because from
a finite set of elements you're able to
recombine and make combinations infinite
combinations so because it has this
compositional quality it actually allows
us to constantly go beyond what we can
imagine so coming back to this idea of
time travel
how do these
physical
soup
of bones and meat that we are inside a
skin shell how do we come up with an
idea like time travel well here's a
simple way that language could help if
you talk about
time as a path that you can travel so if
you can say things like we're
approaching the deadline
as soon as you have that that metaphor
that analogy in place time is a path
that can travel they say wait a second
paths i can travel in any direction
whatever speed i want so why can't i
think about myself now traveling in time
right and it just takes that little that
little analogy to set you off to now
have a thought that goes far beyond what
you can physically experience in your
lifetime so hold on to that thought
because that's exactly where i'd like to
go but let's bring dean back out for a
final three-way conversation here so you
know
it it's an idea that of course is a
trope of science fiction but it's
something that i think we all
have a deep emotional connection to
um
so from the physics standpoint maybe it
wasn't completely clear but it's perhaps
worth being
completely straightforward about it
the qualities of time that i described
at the outset
do allow for time travel time travel is
part and parcel of the laws of physics
as we understand it now i should qualify
that by saying time travel to the future
is what we fully understand so if i want
to travel a million years into the
future there are two ways that einstein
told me i can do it go hang out near a
black hole sufficiently long time come
back perhaps a year goes by for me a
million years go by on planet earth or
get into a rocket ship head out into
space for six months at an appropriate
speed near the speed of light turn
around and come back
get off of that ship i will have aged
one year a million years will have gone
by on planet earth so this is part and
parcel of how the world is constructed
now when it comes to
the intuition that this
type of meandering through time would be
possible because after all as you say
it's just a path and paths you can
meander in any direction is this
something which effectively all cultures
have come to as something that
matters that's important that they would
focus attention on or are there cultures
for whom
it's just so irrelevant
that it would never even come up because
it's just not something they would care
about
well uh some people argue that the idea
of time travel as you described it or
the way that it happens in science
fiction is actually a relatively new
idea that it happens with the machine
age with the industrial age and true
examples of really going to another
place and time don't start happening in
narratives around the world until then i
mean because we couldn't travel far is
that sort of what it comes down to
people
there's certainly lots of time
interesting time distortions that happen
in traditional narratives so for example
in the ramayana story
you can um
have
all the roosters start crowing
earlier than normal to make the day come
sooner because you don't want the prince
to finish all of the castles that you've
assigned him to build because otherwise
you'll have to marry him things like
that you know so there is a time
distortion you can create through more
traditional means right um
so you can think of that as a kind of
time travel it's not maybe strictly the
same kind of idea as you were talking
about but but are there i mean either
cultures or perhaps even
neurological
maladies
that focus
on the present
in a manner that just sort of makes the
past and the future not something that's
vital to that individual's existence
there's this fascinating book um by
daniel everett about don't sleep through
our snakes and he studies the population
of
indigenous amazon in which he claims
that they're very present biased so
that they don't have good words for
long-term future deep time deep future
deep past so
but nobody would call that a
neurological
bias but the interesting part there is
so they use tools but they don't for
example often um and it would frustrate
him um because he would lend them their
tools they wouldn't store them so they
wouldn't say okay i'm going to need this
yeah tomorrow and when you think about
one of the biggest um technological
achievements we've had we talked about
okay carving a obsidian blade
carving a knife out of an obsidian blade
that's part of the story right the other
part of story saying i'm going to use
this blade i'm going to store this blade
because i'm going to use it for this so
that requires
the time travel now in relay but that it
was strange and this is what lara was
referring to
true time travel in the sense of going
to the past and jumping back and forth
only emerged apparently um
in the literature mostly in the late
1800s with
there was a couple of stories about time
distortion but true time travel jumping
back and forth uh a lot of a time
machine
why did it take so long in a way so you
you know you look at shakespeare you
look at the bible you look at all these
stories we look at so many so many
very creative mythologies
which
talking about language's capacity to mix
and match
there are so many
entities that are not in the real world
but are some linguistic mash-up of
things that are in the real world it
doesn't seem like it'd be that hard to
put time into the mix in a way that
would yield all sorts of time travel
stories going all the way back and why
didn't we yeah why didn't we well you
know there are
there are ideas uh about time and
cultures around the world that are hard
to express in english and um and also
hard to understand when you're not from
those cultures yeah and so i can try to
tell you about one and it'll probably
make as much sense as it does to me if i
do it so i'll try um in some aboriginal
cultures in australia
there is a belief that things don't
really change that time
isn't really passing in a sense that
when you're born you are
really a new version of an ancestor that
you had and so that ancestors getting to
relive their life but also there's this
other realm
that is the ancestor realm or that it's
called dream time sometimes and so
everything continues in that dream time
outside of time
now i don't know what i just said
uh right i i can't tell you that i have
a real that i can take the words that i
just used and put it into my
understanding of how time works but i
believe that the people there have some
representation that has that make sense
and i haven't reached it yet
right and so i think we don't fully know
the range of possibilities for thinking
about time because it's hard to go in
and really get wrap your mind around
someone else's understanding in the same
way that you have to intensively train
your undergrads to get them to wrap
their mind around relativity for example
yeah it takes a lot of in training into
that system
so speaking of time we're starting to
run a little low on time but you do jump
in if you had another thought because i
had one final question but go first i
was just going to say in terms of what
it does it is still strange about why it
took us so long for time travel to
appear in fiction um but as you know the
end of the
18th century was a very dynamic
period both scientifically
and
in literature and it was sort of the
time where people like einstein and
poincare were beginning to think
about time more deeply but some people
have made the
maybe what was the critical event that
um
set the stage or planted the seed for
time travel was actually the emergence
of photography
and the ability to store something that
was the first time you could have
faithful reproductions of something in
the past in the sense that made it still
exist
and maybe that allowed us to start
creating stories of going back and
visiting that but it is a mystery and
it's strange that there's so much
stories in
literature where things are
the same themes are hit upon time and
time again but time travel was really
slow to emerge
so so one final question that sort of
relates to that as well
you know we often i think
look at ourselves as
uh blessed by the capacity
to think about the past and imagine the
future i mean it opens up our world in
in a way that makes us human right if
there's like i mean language certainly
makes us human
but this capacity to be able to freely
roam the timeline in our minds is
something that is really iconic to
our species as far as we can tell
at the same time it also creates a great
deal of
anxiety
a great deal of pain and suffering i
mean mindfulness teachers throughout the
ages have focused us on living in the
moment as opposed to this capacity so do
you find that that's
a curious tension how does one deal with
that tension i mean from the from the
neurological standpoint and from the
cognitive science standpoint
any advice on how to deal with that
tension between those two capacities
sure
i think in general being reminded of how
small you are relative to the scale of
uh
universe whether it's in size or in age
is useful when you're concerned about
small things maybe someone said
something annoying in the meeting that
you had in a staff meeting
just think about how many millions of
years the earth has existed and
it'll it'll seem like a small speck i
got to tell you
in 2016 the the most hopeful thought i
had was
four years to 2020 and 13.8 billion
years since the big bang so everything's
going to be just fine
any kind of any kind of perspective yeah
i i
i think that the part of the answer to
that question is is our ability to to
think about time is is itself dynamic
and um
it's true
that
our ability to think about the future
and think about the stresses that are
arising or what we should have done
differently in the past is a major
source of anxiety
the alternative is just to be
like like your dog i think is
like my dog is very um focused on the
present
so the thing is is that
um
in this uh amazonian
tribe that doesn't think much about the
future
the author of the book is pointing out
yes they seem to have less anxiety
but they also have less time to live
their their mortality their lifespan is
shorter because they don't think about
the future so there's a bit of a
catch-22 here right
it's our ability to
think about the future which causes
anxiety which sort of assures that we
have a future
so so but clearly we have to have a
middle ground right in which
and part of this is there's nothing
wrong with being present in the moment
while you think about the future
right so and as scientists you have to
do this where you
focusing on a problem that you want to
resolve sometime in the future so i
think it doesn't take away anything from
the notion of living in the moment or
mindfulness i think that's incredibly um
valid
um approach but that lesson isn't that
we should ignore the future
and this is the problem that we're all
struggling with is we want to ensure
that our relatives and our offspring
have a future and so we still have to
worry about it absolutely when you asked
earlier if there are any neurological
conditions or groups of people who are
very present focused probably the most
present focused are crack addicts
i didn't think that's real really
but that it that that is a group of
people who have a very very uh narrow
time horizon that they're focused on so
you can see they're also downfalls of
extreme present focus
so the balance i think ultimately is a
way of going about it well thank you
both very much for joining us please
join me in thanking
[Applause]
[Music]
you